hey what is up everybody it's axel here
for anime uproar if you haven't heard of
me before i am an editor for the channel
and i cover all of our jiu jitsu kaizen
content for anime uproar that said
today's video is not about jiu jitsu
kaizen and is instead about one of the
most popular antagonist groups in all of
anime being hunter hunter's phantom
troupe in particular we're going to be
talking about who they are and what
their abilities are if you enjoy this
video and want to see more hunter hunter
content on this channel be sure to leave
a like and if you're new here or just
haven't subscribed yet make this the
video that you subscribe to anime uproar
and be sure to click that bell and
select all notifications you can also
follow anime uproar on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar or you can
follow myself at excellionyt of course
this video will contain hunter hunter
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the phantom troop
is an organization led by crolo lucifer
and consisting of up to 12 other
positions they are often depicted as a
spider with crolo being its head each
member also has a spider tattoo with
their number within the group labeled on
it the group was founded in a junkyard
city called meteor city which was
inhabited by castaway's exiles and
people who just don't exist in public
record
basically a city of trash with people
that the rest of the world considered to
be garbage the founding members were
crolo phaeton machi nobunaga pakunoda
franklin and uvogin and it's unclear if
finks or schalnark were there but this
is more or less what the original group
looked like while the group wasn't
entirely bad they primarily did kill and
steal their way into prominence and sure
it was some pretty dark stuff but hey
they became a family in doing so and
placed loyalty above all else truly a
very happy story but with the basics out
of the way let's start with the legs and
work our way to the head
leg number one of the spider is nobunaga
this is our resident samurai complete
with sarashi katana and a top knot he
tends to be one of the friendlier
members of the group however when it
comes to business and hostages he really
isn't one to take things lightly in the
case of the phantom troupe it's pretty
common that most members have some
combination of being incredibly fast or
strong and nobunaga is no exception
however we really just don't know all
that much more about him in terms of his
abilities because he's in the troop we
can assume that his nen ability is
something pretty incredible but we've
just yet to see it so far in fact he is
the only member whose men we don't know
about other than him being an enhancer
despite this he has a powerful aura
about him that makes him one of the most
intimidating members especially when you
take into account his phenomenal
swordsmanship specifically he is an
iaido master stating that anyone who
enters his range could be instantly
killed number two is phaeton he is
probably the most sadistic in the group
tending to be more dark and mysterious
as well but that could also be
attributed to him just not speaking very
frequently and even when he does speak
he's kind of limited in his ability to
do so when he's angered he'll even start
speaking in non-existent language which
is kind of an interesting thing to have
for a character quirk his role in the
group is the interrogator which is
pretty in line with his sadistic
tendencies and love for torture luckily
unlike nobunaga phaeton's nen abilities
are much more available to us firstly
pain packer which protects him both from
his enemies and from his own future
attacks with the big one that we see
being called rising sun an attack that
sees him channeling his aura into a ball
of heat and the more damage he's taken
during the fight the stronger this
becomes essentially just making a
miniature sun that burns his opponents
to death
machi is the third member of the group
and she's probably one of the least
expressive or personable among the group
however it has been shown that she
actually does care about the group
despite this
honestly i've always had a soft spot for
mochi specifically because of her nen
abilities and you know she's also super
cute but either way machi can create
strings out of nen and if you know how
much i love vanessa in black clover you
know i'm pretty much down for this we've
seen her use this in two different ways
firstly she can create nen stitches
which can help to reattach limbs and
help with several minor injuries as well
or she can use nen threads to bind or
choke her opponents or just take control
of their movements like puppets while
these threads are still attached to
machi they are nearly invincible meaning
you can neither cut or rip them but once
she lets go this durability stops
our first look at number four was hisoka
he is entirely chaotic and willing to do
or work with anyone necessary to get a
fight with someone powerful at the end
of the day he is team hisoka and if that
means pretending to be a troop member
for a short period of time because he
wants to fight crollo then he's probably
going to do that the downside of this
being that he's a little too interested
in power and potential and even if
someone is i don't know for example a
young boy with spiky hair he becomes
completely devoted to the idea of
fighting them even to the point of
arousal but yeah at the end of the day
he's just a sociopathic clown who
falsely joined the troop to get his
rocks off at the chance of fighting the
leader hisoka is likely one of the most
well-rounded people in the entire series
in terms of power let alone just in the
troop this isn't to say he's unstoppable
by any means but he is fast strong
sneaky and smart enough to keep up with
just about anyone he can come across on
top of that he's durable enough to keep
the battle going if the person
overpowers him he also has a pretty big
leg up in most battles due to his nen
ability bungie gum which has the
property of both rubber and gum bungee
gum is basically an aura that hisoka can
exude from his body to create elastic
threads barriers or glue as well as a
slew of other things he can attach this
to any kind of surface that he wants to
gain an advantage through manipulating
his environment he really is only
limited by his ingenuity in a way that
most other nen users aren't and his
ability to think on his feet and use his
bungee gum in new and dynamic ways makes
him one of the most interesting
characters in the series when it comes
to fights he can also attach or detach
bungie gum to people or objects as well
creating slings or even drawing his
opponents in for free hits
if projectiles are coming for him he can
just make a wall of bungee gum to launch
them back or he can even just apply it
to the soles of his feet to keep his
position steady this ability honestly
feels like he could do just about
anything if hisoka has enough time to
figure out the situation we also saw him
use bungie gum in a more manipulative
and tricky way in texture surprise
basically he uses his aura and bungee
gum to apply materials to his skin and
replicate a desired look and feel we saw
him using this to confuse castro to hide
his wounds and we also saw him using
this to apply a fake phantom troop
tattoo on himself to show false loyalty
however he left the group pretty early
on and was replaced by kaluto zoldik
kaluto is both the youngest and weakest
member of the troop and while he was
with the zoldix he was essentially just
a very quiet and obedient person that
said once he joins the troop he begins
opening up quite a bit
kaluto is just kind of a super cool
character altogether just like kilauea
he has been trained to be an assassin so
he's very stealthy and can use rhythm
echo and also just like kilauea he has a
pretty unique weapon using a paper fan
that said he can empower this fan to
even be strong enough to cut steel
speaking of paper though most of
kaluto's nen abilities revolve around it
he can make paper dolls of a person that
he attached a piece of confetti to and
after doing so he'll be able to hear
anything that happens around that person
super useful for gathering information
then there's the dance of the serpent
fang which is where he drops a bunch of
confetti and then forms it into a giant
snake-like cyclone of paper that tears
enemies apart and he can do this on
repeat if needed number five is finx who
to me at least probably has my least
favorite male character design in the
group mostly because like
well look at him he's just kind of a
dude anyways as you might guess by
looking at him he's pretty quick to
anger and get into arguments with the
other members but overall he still does
get along with them while we do have
some information on his nen we still
really don't know the limits of what he
can do yet he is a great hand-to-hand
fighter in just about every sense but
when he needs to he can also use
ripper's cyclotron this is the only net
ability we've seen from him so far and
it sees him spinning his arm in a
clockwise fashion with each revolution
storing power for his next attack for
reference it took about 15 spins to kill
a chimera ant but he did say that half
that much would have been fine next up
we have a bit of a confusing situation
as number six and nine is either shall
narc or pakunoda each of these members
is unfortunately dead now so we can't
exactly ask them to figure it out and
these are also the first positions which
we haven't seen replaced yet after the
character is passed on let's start with
pakunoda because it kind of follows the
trend of being a dull character design
that said as a character she's pretty
great beyond that
very proud and intimidating but also
super loyal to the point where she would
sacrifice herself for the betterment of
the group pakunoda despite not really
being a fighter was typically able to
hold her own pretty well her nan ability
is what really makes her special though
psychometry which i'm probably
mispronouncing let me know in the
comments if i am allows her to read
people's memories to expose weaknesses
or secrets couple this with her innate
ability to tell when people are lying
and he got a pretty powerful tool in
collecting information she could even
use this to see objects which were
previously in an area to get a better
sense of what happened in a room this
could also be coupled with her weapons
by shooting memories into people's heads
with conjured bullets called memory
bombs if she extracted someone's
memories beforehand and shot that memory
back into their mind though it would
cause them to lose that memory entirely
and that brings us to shall narc he was
one of the physically weakest in the
troop but he was also one of the most
intellectual he's kind of the nerd of
the group loving to play with
electronics and toy-like things more so
than fight people directly at first
glance he might seem like one of the
kindest however he's probably one of the
least empathetic in the entire group
valuing his own life very little and the
lives of others even less often
referring to them as playthings or toys
his ability black voice allows him to
stick an antenna onto someone and then
control them like a puppet or setting
them onto autopilot he could also put
himself on autopilot which essentially
makes him go super saiyan for a short
time he gets massive buffs to his
strength and speed however he won't be
able to leave autopilot until the
mission is complete and afterwards he's
in immense pain and loses his memory of
the entire event number seven is
franklin probably the member with the
most passion and loyalty for the troop
even if it's in a pretty kind of twisted
way if it came down to it he would
gladly kill every other member of the
troop and restart it from scratch if it
meant that the troop could continue in
some way luckily it didn't come down to
that his net ability is pretty
straightforward he can turn his fingers
into machine guns which have devastating
power
he even decided to cut off the tips of
his own fingers to create a self-imposed
limitation drastically increasing the
ability's effect and there really isn't
that much more to what he can do he's
just frankenstein with machine guns for
hands
number eight is my personal favorite
member of the group shizuku this is of
course excluding crolo and hisoka who
are kind of in their own situations
but honestly i mean both her and machi
are top tier waifus and i won't hear any
slander against them in the comments
shizuku has a horribly bad memory and
will even forget the names of the people
she knows pretty well and she can often
be presented as being very cold or
almost even soulless rarely reacting to
anything her nan ability is blinky which
is adorable but still horrifying blinky
is a vacuum cleaner who can absorb an
infinite amount of non-living things but
it won't suck up anything that's alive
or made of men furthermore it can vomit
up the last thing that it absorbed if
it's needed this is particularly useful
to the group as it allows her to suck up
things like traps or even just bloody
crime scenes this might not seem like
the most effective thing in combat but
she does manage pretty well using blinky
as a club on top of that if the opponent
has any cuts or bleeding wounds she can
have blinky suck up all of the blood in
their body until they're drained dry
bona lenov is member number 10 and might
be
the most forgettable character in the
entire group to me he is a boxer covered
in bandages to look almost like a mummy
which should be pretty unique and
memorable but i don't know something
about him just never jumped out to me
the reason he looks like this is because
under all of the bandages and gloves his
body is riddled with holes when he
fights these holes make a kind of music
that he's able to kind of move and dance
to throughout the battle and on top of
that all of his nun abilities revolve
around that music this effect is called
battle canterbile prologue it's more or
less just the music created through the
hole and the effects that it can create
the most powerful ability that we've
seen come out of this though is battle
cantable jupiter summoning a mini
jupiter to crush any opponent who can
hear his music and i know i said mini
jupiter but like mini in the sense that
it isn't as big as the actual planet the
thing is still pretty damn huge
our original number 11 was uvogin
basically this is sabretooth from marvel
on steroids he is incredibly fast strong
and resistant to pain and is easily the
strongest physically in the troop even
just his scream is able to kill people
around him all of that makes sense when
you consider him a very proficient nen
enhancer though speaking of nen his main
move was big bang impact focusing all of
his energy into one fist and then
punching his target so hard that he
creates an explosion equal to that of a
missile of course he was taken out
pretty early on and replaced by our
current number 11 illumi zoldic this is
kilua's big brother and just generally a
just very creepy non-emotive character
that for much of the story was kind of
the boogeyman and he fits that bill
pretty effectively he does however seem
to have a pretty good sense of humor
when it comes to being around hisoka
much like kaluto ilumi is also an
assassin so he has the training in all
those normal assassin abilities albeit
to a much stronger degree than kaluto
does he also has access to netan and
he's a manipulator with a lot of weird
stuff at his disposal he's able to
manipulate bodies freely using needles
to hold those changes in place which
allows him to look like other people as
a result he can also implant needles in
people's brains to hypnotize them for
example leading to kilauea's drastic
fear of him
or control corpses or even large groups
of people by attaching needles to them
all of this as someone who is terrified
of needles is just the grossest thing
possible but when it comes to an
antagonist who is meant to be creepy
it's pretty perfect
finally we have our last leg and the
last deceased member being number 12
cortopi he is an incredibly short
cyclops knockoff version of cousin it
from the addams family and yes i know he
has two eyes do not get nitpicky with me
you know what i mean we rarely ever see
him talking and all he ever really does
is agree with what other people ask of
him again kind of a forgettable
character however his design at least is
unique i guess courtopy's abilities are
more in line with support being able to
make exact copies of anything that he
touches that said he can't create life
so if he copies a person you would
basically have an inanimate copy of that
person the copies last for about a day
and then vanish but for the entirety of
their existence he's able to know
exactly where they are by touching the
original and that leads us to the leader
of the troop chrollo lucifer this man
has a lot going on but if i had to
describe him i think charismatic would
be the word that i chose he is a natural
leader and easily gets people to follow
him and act according to his will at
face value he comes across as very soft
polite and caring and to a large degree
that's very genuine which is often why
people are drawn to him in the first
place but he's also a cunning strategist
who makes the most out of every
situation and knows what people want
crollo's goal in every situation is to
have perspective on the world and the
people around him at all times but at
the end of the day if he has a mission
in place he will gladly use anyone he
needs to or cause a massacre to complete
that mission and speaking of using
people let's get into his nen ability
skill hunter with this he conjures a
book with a large handprint on it and if
very specific restrictions have been met
he can steal the net abilities of
another person leaving the original
owner with no access to it these
conditions are seeing an ability being
used with his own eyes asking the target
questions about their nen and then
having them answer it and then having
them touch their palm to the cover of
his book
all within one hour then to actually use
the stolen ability krollo needs to open
the book to the correct page and keep it
open until he's done with that ability
on top of all of that if the original
owner of the netability dies they are
removed from the book unless the ability
is copied after that person died which
is complicated enough in its own right
to make a pretty solid set of
restrictions now the part about needing
to keep the book open has a bit of a
loophole to it using double face crollo
is able to keep the book open onto a
specific page without the use of his own
hands and he can even bookmark it to
another page effectively allowing him to
fight freely while using two stolen
techniques at once to date we've only
seen him use nine stolen abilities which
i will cover super briefly because
otherwise we'd be here all day these
include indoor fish which summon fish
skeletons inside of a sealed room these
fish will devour people however while
they do so the targets will remain alive
conscious and free of pain throughout
the entire experience fun fun cloth can
shrink anything a created cloth covers
until it fits in the user's palm
teleportation is well teleportation the
sun and moon marks each of crolo's hand
with either a sun or a moon then he can
touch a person with his hand to leave
that correlating mark on them if he
manages to touch the symbol again with
the other hand that person will explode
kind of like being a very flashy version
of soy phone from bleach order stamp
allows him to tell corpses what to do if
they still have a head by placing a mark
on them convert hands allows him to make
someone else take on his appearance or
to take on their appearance himself
lovely ghost writer allows him to
predict the future of a person if they
write their full name birthday and blood
type on a piece of paper although he is
unable to check his own future and these
prophecies will always take the form of
a poem gallery fake was copied from
cortopi which just allows him to make
copies the same way that courtope did
but when combined with order stamp
allows him to essentially create a
zombie puppet army and black voice was
borrowed from shelnark and allows him to
manipulate people with an antenna
and that's it we have officially cleared
a quick look through every phantom troop
member and their abilities which members
are your favorites and which abilities
do you like most as far as characters go
i think i like crollo hisoka shizuku and
then machi while in terms of abilities i
really like kaluto krollo and machi i'd
love to hear what you think in the
comments down below though and are there
any phantom troop members that you don't
like very much i know they tend to be
very hit or miss so i'd like to hear
what you guys think if you guys enjoyed
this hunter hunter video though and want
to see more on the channel please leave
a like and if you're new to anime uproar
remember to subscribe and ring the bell
by selecting all notifications you can
guarantee that you will not miss any
videos in the future and of course if
you want to follow anime upper on
twitter and instagram you can check out
at anime uproar or you can find myself
at excellionyt i want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible special thanks to alpha sigma
who is an absolute mad lad and disciple
of lord tuigo himself and of course are
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans these being
ingrada patahefa al-jatal hinokami and
water the toasted chi the spike
8227 dylan isadore spidey life tennelle
tungsten tarcus baked buddhist and
monkey d quilly and finally thank you to
all of our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh the red haired raven
angel cruise ratherwin de ora very gucci
alicia octor bonnie parks joanne garcia
ted not ted fatboy games corey mcgowan
and soul ray slice and dice if you enjoy
our videos and feel like they provide
some kind of value to you please
consider checking out our patreon
through the link in the description
anyone who supports the channel with
even a single dollar has access to our
exclusive patreon only discord and your
name will appear at the end of videos
just like all of these phenomenal people
but for now i want to thank you all so
much for watching and until next time
remember to stay active
[Music]
bye